I think yeah just villages in general
there isn't a lot of help coming through
but from since I've got her actually
there is a lot more help which is
actually great to hear and it's nice to
see not only from the government more
now but actually a lot of locals from
the UK a lot of my dad's friends and
people like myself are out here doing
what we can to help as many people as we
can you know it is not gonna lie it's a
bit of a it's a bit of a war zone here
or just in the city and like some of the
scenes it's like unbelievable I've never
seen anything like it
I'm sure and uh all the more credit to
you put for making the journey to talk
us through
how how things have developed in your
mind since since Monday and when you
made the decision to get out there and
and the journey and and the status uh
you find yourself in now
if I'm being honest I'm not gonna lie I
feel real guilty of walking down FW with
my latte and not and having the power to
do something about and not do something
about it so me and my family some of my
dad's friends we flew out
um we got as much Goods as we can we're
getting cash out as well but since we've
got here a lot of people have also come
and actually given a lot of people what
they need as in like food what they're
missing out on so is actually things
like tents that they can't actually get
at a minute but food water that they now
have I actually think it's
better to actually give people cash so
they can use it for what they need at
certain times because it's it's weird
after I saw what I saw today I was like
I can create a gofund page and raise 20
30 grand but then where's that exactly
going to go and actually really make a
huge impact on their life and I know
that might sound a little bit silly but
it's absolute chaos and someone needs to
kind of like take control of the
situation as much as they can and help
as many people as they can as fairly as
possible you know it's really chaotic
it's really hard to explain actually
no I mean I I can believe it and uh that
sort of sense of of chaos uh your those
people you know in in the region uh your
dad's friends I think you mentioned who
do they is there a sense of blame on
that or do they actually understand that
uh of course this is a crazy uh
unprecedented situation and it's going
to be impossible to to help everyone in
a coordinated fashion instantly
they understand it's crazy but they're
also people that have been raised around
here and it's a crazy environment to be
raised around you know a lot of these
people around here they come from
suffering it's almost like they're used
to an element of suffering so obviously
it hits hard when they're seeing their
families on the buildings but it's just
I guess it's just a hard one to tackle
because you look at the city itself and
it's just
it's just everything's like
nothing's there there's no City left and
it's and it's quiet it's like I said
it's like a war zone it's difficult to
take in actually
and and you mentioned uh the the idea of
giving out money
um what other things in particular do
you feel like the people in in the rural
areas need is there also a lack of sort
of expert rescue workers or or without
the sort of high-rise buildings is is
that perhaps less less key what people
need
so what's happening is we've I think
like there needs to be an expert that
needs to kind of take control of what's
Happening there's people literally just
walking down the streets and trying to
hear a noise and once they hear a noise
they hear potentially a voice they then
get
experts I don't know who to go and try
and do something about it but then you
see like 40 people in one place and you
kind of don't know who's doing what or
who's taking control and that's no
disrespect to anyone here they're
obviously doing what they can and it's
obviously very tough it's just there's
so much
there's so all the buildings are all
over the Florida City there is no City
left so it's like there's so much pain
and it's so difficult to control like
someone needs to come and really like do
something about it or just take control
of the whole situation which again is
very hard
and what are the conditions like I mean
I don't know how many days you've been
there now and how many days uh you plan
to stay but uh do you feel for your own
safety and and well-being out there I
mean talk us through the conditions
you know what the city again there is an
element of panic even just like
20 minutes ago when we were driving
someone actually hit the front of the
car we're fine luckily but there is an
element of panic but I feel safe and
everyone here is looking after each
other you know the locals everyone
understands that there's a lot of pain
going on right now so everyone is doing
what they can to look after each other
everyone is being extra nice everyone is
doing what they can everyone is giving
away what they have to people that need
it without no thought process you know
in Turkish and Kurdish people you know
are probably one of the best people when
it comes to hospitality so when it comes
to stuff like that they're very good at
sharing so in that element yes it's
great do I feel safe I feel safe but
I feel sad and I don't know what's going
to happen to all of these poor people in
the future I don't know how that city is
going to recover and that's like the
saddest thing you know
and and I guess just just finally
um what what message you might have for
people back here I mean clearly you have
Family Ties uh and that's been an extra
incentive for you to get over there and
and help yeah but uh what other messages
do you have for for broader people back
here in the UK watching
I think it's important that people like
are very aware of what's happening and
the suffering people are going through
here I think it's important to
acknowledge that and if you are going to
take action on it I think
smart people and people that have the
power should come together and actually
do something that's going to make a huge
impact on the individuals here like I
said it's easy to do a gofund page and
throw money and get random bits but I
think there needs to be like a group of
smart individuals that get together and
actually help rebuild the communities
and Villages and towns around here
that's what I would advise and that's
what I would want to do with my friends
yeah Darren thanks uh thanks so much for
joining us and uh and uh good luck again
with the with the work that you're doing
um out there and I hope it's a
successful stay stay safe